رغم الاعلان الاسرائيلي عن ان المرحله
الثانيه قد بدات لكن هي ليست بمفهوم مرحله
ثانيه هي توسيع الاطار العملياتي والقتالي
للمرحله الاولى وتزامن بعد الاعلان مباشره
ان تم تحركت القوات الاسرائيليه ووسعت
اطار العمليات في منطقه الزيتون وجبالي
البلد
والمخيم وبالتالي هي توسيع لاطار العمليات
ولا تعتبر مرحله ثانيه بالمفهوم العسكري
الان ما هي التداعيات لهذا العمل هي
محاوله فتح اكثر من
جبهه من اجل تشتيت جهد المدافعين وحرمانه
من عمليات الاسناد المتبادل لكن ال اداره
المعركه الدفاعيه تتغلب على ذلك كما اعتقد
من حيث انه بنيت على اسس قواطع جغرافيه
فلكل قاطع قواته المخصصه وا مهامه المحدده
فلا اعتقد انها ستربك او تؤثر بصوره كبيره
نعم ستحدث مزيد من الدمار مزيد من القتل
في المدنيين مزيد من عمليات النزوح
الداخلي لكنها بالمطلق لن تؤثر على الخطه
الدفاعيه كما اتوقع الان فيما يتعلق بال
بقيه قطاع غزه المنطقه الجنوبيه جنوب وادي
غزه اعتقد ان هذا العمل اي عمليات عسكريه
رغم انها عمليات القصف ومحاولات التسلل
قائمه لكن ان تتحول الى حرب شامله ومفتوحه
على ال بقيه قطاع غزه وهو مساحته تقريبا
220 مكم اي ما يقارب ضعف مساحه القاطع
الشمالي هذا مرهون ب عوامل سياسيه
ومدى نجاعه ضغط الشارع سواء في داخل
الكيان المحتل او الدول الاوروبيه على
متخذ القرار ان لا يتوسع في العمليات
ومرتبط ومرتهن كليا بنتائج معرك المعركه
في مدينه غزه ومحيطه yeah